So the answer is 13. And the reason for this is quite
interesting. If you look at the answers we were getting so far, this
is the number of calls for each number. So when we had fibo
36, the number of calls was 1. When the input was 35,
the number of calls was also 1. When the input was 34, the number of calls was 2.
When the input was 33, the number of calls
was 3. When the input was 32, the number
of calls was 5. We should start to
notice a pattern. This is exactly the Fibonacci series
that we're computing here. Every time we decrease n
by 1, so to get the number of calls
for 32, we added the number of calls for 1 before and the number of calls for
2 before, and if you look at the structure
of this, it follows from the same rule that
we had, thinking about the number of rabbits reproducing.
That everyone that we have on the previous level,
leads to two more. And that means as we
do this addition, we have all the previous calls.
So we had 1 call the 34 at the
previous level. We're going to produce two new calls but
the inputs are different. But if we look at
the way the inputs are distributed, we have 2 plus
1 here. We have 1 plus 1 for 34. We have 2 plus 1 for 33. For 32 we
have 2 plus 3. We have 5. For 31,
we're going to have eight calls, and for 30, we're going to
have 5 plus 8, which is 13. And
this will keep going. These numbers will get quite
big very fast. And the number of calls we
need, every time we evaluate fibo 36, so the
evaluate the number of calls, when we started
with 36 that's going to be the result of fibo
36 minus n minus 1. So the number of
calls we'll need to fibo 2 in evaluating fibo
36 will be fibo 33 calls, and we don't
know what that number is yet. Because when we tried
to evaluate fibonacci 36, using our recursive definition, our
evaluator timed out, so we're in big trouble. If we
want to figure out how many calls there are,
we need a more efficient way of computing Fibonacci numbers.
So let's see if we can do that. And
the reason this was so inefficient was because we're doing
all this redundant work, right? We saw that to
compute fibonacci 36, well we had to compute fibonacci 35,
and we had to compute fibonacci 34, all of
this work computing fibonacci 34. We did the same exact
thing over here, right? This is producing the same
output. There's tons and tons of redundant computation going on.
So if we're going to compute this more efficiently, we
don't want to duplicate all that work. We need to do
it in a way, where we don't need
to keep recomputing the same thing. So the solution
to this, is instead of using a recursive procedure
to compute fibonacci. We're going to compute fibonacci using
a while loop. Anything that we can define recursively,
we can also define without using a recursive definition.
It's often much easier and cleaner to think about
things, with a recursive definition, but it's often not
the fastest way to calculate things. And certainly, in this
case, because of all the redundant computation, it's a very, very
inefficient way to calculate fibonacci. So let's try to do this
with a while loop instead and we'll make that a quiz.